Say goodbye to drills as a new cavity-filling
technique that uses electrical current could
be available to the public in three years.
And a fungus in the soil of Nova Scotia has
been found to help combat antibiotic-resistant
superbugs.
So on behalf of the rest of the world - thank
you Canadian dirt!
Vsauce, Kevin here.....This is Mind Blow.
The Cruise RP-1 is the first highway autopilot
for your car.
The device keeps your car in its lane a safe
distance from the car in front of you and
is always watching the road even if you aren't.
It can be installed on your existing vehicle
so you can sit back and let the car do the
work by controlling the steering, throttle
and braking.
And they're taking pre-orders for 2015 right
now.
The Cozy Room lets you hide from everything.
The Japanese relaxation room comes with space
for a TV or computer, shelves to display collections,
and a personal desk.
It costs $8,000 but unfortunately doesn't
come with plumbing, a refrigerator, or air
conditioning.
Pelty is a high quality speaker that runs
off of the power from a single wax candle.
It turns the thermal energy from the candle
into enough electric energy to power the speaker
and amplify the music.
And it has no wires and connects via bluetooth
making it eco-friendly and easy to transport.
A group of chimps have created a fashion trend.
When popular chimp Julie stuck a piece of
grass in her ear back in 2010 it caught on
with all the other chimps..... now they're
all doing it.
So yeah.
The ReWalk is the first FDA approved exoskeleton
for use in the home and in the community.
The robotic device enables hip and knee motion
allowing those with spinal cord injuries to
stand.
When the user tilts forward the walking motion
is activated and repeated shifting creates
a sequence of steps.
The Rewalk has the ability to sit, stand,
turn, and climb stairs giving paraplegics
extensive mobility options to explore.
Eta is a human-powered bike capable of going
133.8 km/hour.
And it looks like a giant bullet on wheels.
The rider sits comfortably inside and uses
displays from cameras to see the road.
It won't be able to be used on highways any
time soon due to its inability to survive
a collision and low visibility.
But they hope that in the future this technology
could be used for a cleaner alternative to
driving.
Engineers at the University of Illinois are
creating biobots.
These biological robots are powered by muscle
cells and controlled with electrical impulses.
They're using skeletal muscle cells because
of their ability to be controlled, making
it possible to customize each bot for a specific
task or application.
This is the first step in developing biological
machines that can be programmed and trained
to do work.
Luke Butcher of Cambridge believes skinny
wormholes could be kept stable long enough
to send a beam of light carrying a message
anywhere in the universe or throughout time
itself.
This is theoretical but awesome.
Smart Bricks are like giant Lego for building
houses, bridges and sidewalks.
The large concrete Kite Bricks are designed
to be easily joined together and the company
claims these building materials provide a
50% reduction in building costs and they hope
to implement the technology everywhere from
Africa to Manhattan.
British airways created a happiness blanket.
It changes color to reflect the mood of the
wearer by measuring electrical fluctuations
with a headband and sending the information
to fibre optic lights woven into the fabric.
With red means stressed and blue meaning relaxed.
They used the information to test changes
they had made onboard, such as entertainment
and sleeping options, so they could see the
actual physical effects these had on passengers.
The EKOCYCLE is a 3D printer that uses post
consumer waste as printing material.
Each cartridge turns three 20oz plastic bottles
into anything from accessories to decorations.
And they say it's not just a tool for making
but remaking things and changing the way people
think about recycling.
Finally, Confluence is a short film using
macro and microscopes shot in 4k with a red
camera
I'm gonna leave you with a crash-proof drone
and as always.... thanks for watching.